Speaker 1: hey, this is the best Donald Trump
flipped out because a jury has acquitted
Hillary Clinton's lawyer. This if you haven't been
following this story, this is the absolute best.
Former Hillary Clinton campaign attorney Michael
Sussman has been acquitted of lying to the FBI
about Donald Trump and Russia during the
2016 election. This was supposed to be the
big smoking gun. Trump was talking about this.
Others have been talking about this. With regard
to the 2016 election, we were finally going
to get the proof of everything Hillary did to
me during my campaign, as Trump liked to say. And
the verdict, indeed, is that Mr. Sussman has been
acquitted. A Clinton campaign lawyer, Michael
Sussman, found not guilty of lying to the FBI in
a blow to the Durham investigation. Trump's been
talking about this Durham investigation for months
and months and months. A Hillary Clinton campaign
lawyer, Michael Sussman, was acquitted of lying
to the FBI, the first trial of special counsel
John Durham's investigation. The verdict is a
major defeat for Durham and his Justice Department
prosecutors who have spent three years looking for
wrongdoing in the Trump-Russia probe. He claimed
Susman lied during a 2016 meeting in which he
passed a tip to the FBI about Trump and Russia.
The jury deliberated for 6 hours over two days
and Ravel and reached a verdict. The case revolved
around Sussman 2016 meeting with James Baker,
a friend who was the FBI's general counsel. Susman
passed along a tip which led to a four month FBI
inquiry into a possible Internet backchannel
between the Trump Organization and the Kremlin
linked Alfa Bank. Both companies denied the
claim. The FBI found no improper cyberlink's.
So here is Susman speaking about the verdict, and
then I'm going to show you how Trump flipped out.
Speaker 3: I have a few thoughts to share
now that the trial has ended. First,
I told the truth to the FBI and the jury clearly
recognized. Were there unanimous verdict today.
I'm grateful to the members of the jury
for their careful and thoughtful service,
despite being falsely.
Speaker 2: Accused. I'm relieved
that justice ultimately prevailed in my case.
Speaker 1: So this is called due process,
and Trump absolutely flips out on
his platform. Truth, social truth.
Speaker 2: Central.
Speaker 1: Saying our legal system
is corrupt. Our judges and justices are highly
partizan, compromised or just plain scared.
Our borders are open. Our elections are rigged.
Inflation is rampant. Gas prices and food costs
are through the roof. Our military leadership is
woke. Our country is going to hell. And Michael
Sussman is not guilty. How's everything
else doing? Enjoy your day. This was a
jury that acquitted him. This was the people.
If they are for law and order and due process,
then this man is not guilty. Due process has
taken place. It has been adjudicated. Remember
when Trump said that Durham's case was going
to be bigger than Watergate and it was going to
expose the biggest political crime of the century,
which, when asked, Trump said, You know what it
is? He wouldn't even say what it was. Obama Gate.
None of these things are anything. And Fox News
immediately running with the o. The jury. The
jury. The jury was in d.c. it was a bad jury.
This is due process and they don't
like the outcome. Take a look at this.
Speaker 5: But it was given the auspice of being
true, not because of a media report, but because
of an FBI investigation into President Trump. And
at the center of that was this Sussman meeting and
Michael Sussman, the prosecutor in this case,
Britton Schall, argued that he wanted a, quote,
October surprise, that that was at the heart of
his intentions. It doesn't appear that the jury
bought that. But I think David Spunt raises a
key point. Here is the D.C. jury pool. This is
a area of our country where 76% of people in the
District of Columbia are registered Democrat. This
was a jury pool of 37 that was whittled down to
a smaller number. But of those 37 jurors, there
were many avowed Clinton supporters who said they
had donated to the Clinton campaign. Some of those
individuals weren't chosen, but about a third of
that jury pool was either a Clinton supporter or
had strong feelings about the election.
Speaker 1: Listen, in every case
in the Rittenhouse case, in in any case,
there's always some beliefs on the jury
that might superficially seem in some way
adversarial to one side or the other. But we have
a process for jury selection during which people
are asked, do you think you can fairly evaluate
the facts? And if the facts point this way or
that way, you would be able to and people say,
Yes, I would or No, I wouldn't. It's the same
jury selection process you have anywhere.
And this is an absurd post-hoc justification.
Speaker 5: And prosecutors were very frustrated
that they would not get a fair shake
here. So I think this does raise questions
on how fair of a shake you could be
given in D.C. But the jury pool that
does oftentimes weigh partizan in one direction.
Speaker 1: You can't prosecute Republicans in
Washington, D.C., Washington, D.C. is let me see.
Washington, D.C., Republican, Democrat percentage.
Um. I guess it's like roughly 70 something
percent. I mean, the, you know, Republican
led prosecution and no Democratic defendant can
be fairly evaluated because there's just too many
Democrats in Washington, D.C. This is essentially
what they are saying. These people are shameless.
They are only concerned with the consequences.
This is the due process they claim to be about.
This is the law and order they claim to be about.
The Durham investigation was allowed to happen.
Nobody interfered with it. They were able to bring
charges. They were able to show we have at least
probable cause or probable cause maybe is the
wrong term. A judge said there is enough here
to move forward and have a trial. You got a jury.
Prosecution and defense were allowed to evaluate
the jury. They settled on a jury. They had the
trial. They had deliberations. They had a verdict.
It was in DC. Of course he was
acquitted. Of course he was acquitted.
They will never be satisfied with law and order if
it doesn't give them the outcome that they want.
And, I mean, is this set for for the
Durham probe? Probably not. But we
are going to continue to follow it. It's
not feeling like the Durham investigation
is going to expose the so-called biggest crime
of the century. It's not my sense that that's
the direction that it's going. Let me know. We'll
be posting these stories on our Facebook page,
Facebook.com slash The David Pakman Show. We'll
take a quick break and be back right after this